[Music]
oh wow
it's so nice here
it's almost messed up how nice it is
like i knew it wouldn't have graffiti
but i think that's a
banksy aisha
aisha are you even listening to me
no no not at all that is the hottest man
i've ever seen
oh my god he's coming shut up shut up hi
um do either of you know aisha i'm her
bayside buddy
yeah i'm aisha it's great to meet you
this is don't remember i'm jamie spano
if you watch it i'm in episode 204 the
big game at the end i scored the losing
touchdown i didn't know you played
football jamie really cause he's
literally been holding a football all
day huh
oh
you know aisha used to play bad guy
douglas you did
like on the boys team uh i mean i didn't
want to but they
cut the girls athletic program i
challenge you to a football off after
school we'll prove who the better
football player is once and for all
isn't that what the football tryout was
for
you wish that was a try out this is a
try off
fine see you on the 50-yard line
no
i have a better idea
we'll do it on the football field
[Music]
you ready to do this yeah
i'm also ready to do this
whoa whoa whoa whoa you brought a
feelings helmet to a football off
that's crazy
look i'm sharing my feelings right now
which is something i hate doing
because i have to put this in terms that
you can understand
yesterday should have been the best day
of my life
i'm in a school where i don't know
anyone and i was made quarterback of the
football team
and since then all that you said is that
i don't deserve it
do you know how small that makes me feel
small as a
baby ladybug
i'm better at football than you
deep down you have to know that
and if you're as good at football as you
say you are be good at this part
be my teammate man
you're right
you are better at football than me
i'm really sorry it's okay
you're better than me at feelings
hug
[Applause]
yes
hey handsome oh hey lexi i see you
decided to roll stella like me oh no
actually i have a date oh and i owe you
a thank you because you're the one who
gave me the idea to ask a friend
oh aisha
yeah that's great right thanks have so
much fun you too
me too
very cool dress you click a cupcake if
you have a rain
i love this song it was played at my
first wedding
okay great maybe i'll see you in class
hey um jamie can we talk sure um i'll
start have you ever noticed how all m ms
tastes exactly the same except when
they're in a skittles bag okay maybe
i'll start um
look
we all love your pep talks i was just
wondering if they could be a little bit
more
inspirational like you can talk more
about winning and a little less about
this stupid touchy-feely stuff
okay i see what's going on here this is
because we went to the dance together
isn't it what yeah you're nagging me
because you had like a really good time
at the dance even though we went as
friends and now you don't know whether
to ask me out or not
no way what makes you think that
i kind of feel the same way
you do
i uh i owe you a thank you
for what we didn't get the w
maybe not
but we got something more important we
got the end
for knowledge
you know you're right
it does feel good to get fired up and
actually try to win
well
that's something i guess
come get pizza with us
hey fast think aisha
i did it wrong
again whoever you're texting must be
pretty funny who is it gabriel iglesias
or your boyfriend jamie oh my god stop i
don't like jamie i mean look at this
how did he make hallway harder to spell
i know jamie's hot but even if he did
like me i can never date this dummy
oh i how do you record yikes wouldn't
want to send that
oh god i sent that
to him take it back here think about
that harry new policy you'll get your
phone back at the end of the day no you
can't calm down
life only gets worse
maybe jamie's phone got taken away
before he saw it
that's a possibility
oh
ayesha let's stop playing games well i
mean except for football
and also you should know that i'm
full-on addicted to call of duty but uh
what i'm trying to say is
will you go to dinner with me tonight
life's so short
let's make it lunch lunch
that's even more romantic
[Music]
this is so nice jamie
maybe too nice i i mean you don't really
know me i could be the kind of person
who says mean things behind people's
back for no reason no i couldn't imagine
that and i'm great at imagining here
check it out
blue cat on a bike
he just ate a pizza
you are good at that thank you
oh i hope it's okay i ordered for us
how'd you know
because i listen to you
and also because your instagram handle
is get you someone who looks at you like
i look at pigs in a blanket
that's funny that's how i imagine you
laughing when you text lol
stop eavesdropping pervs we're not we're
the bayside acapella group
this is so fun
we should do it again tomorrow
yeah uh
jamie what would you want to do together
if we only had today
like i was gonna die tomorrow
or more specifically at 3 p.m today when
we get our phones back oh
that's easy i'd like to spend your final
hours having the most perfect romantic
day of all time
yeah
me too
oh
that time we were just listening
[Music]
what are you doing here do not use the
emergency safety shower
[Music]
[Music]
hi max
oh hey that's my phone
you can go through it if you want the
passcode is 8008.
boob
wait
you don't care if i go through your
phone no that's crazy that
there's not weird stuff on here you
don't want me to see oh yeah there
definitely is but what's the point of
starting a relationship if it's not from
a place of complete trust you know oh
come on every relationship starts with a
couple little lies right
you've never done that before
no of course not
aisha we just spent the most perfect day
together why would i ruin that by
deceiving you
you're right
i know jamie is hot but even if he did
like me i can never date this dummy
hey
um
i'm so sorry
i only said what i said because i knew
that i liked you
and i didn't know if you felt the same
way
i was the one who was dumb for sleeping
um save it
because you're right
i am hot
and sometimes i can't be done
like right now for instance i'm being
dumb enough to think that the amazing
day we just had together
means more than
one bad tax
jamie presents from your ex-lovers
oh
weird i'll open them later
oh look
this one's already open
wow
it's an oculus from holly
she got you an oculus
and sienna got you floor seats to the
lakers clippers game how farful
isn't that the last game you went to
before your grandpa passed
a laker girl hugged him and grandpa got
a streak of her boob makeup on his face
i've always liked sienna for an
instagram cheer liberty she was really
down to earth
you know what i'm gonna go find daisy
i'll come with you no
stay here and open your presents
are you sure
wait are you mad at me
jamie i swear to you i'm not well you're
mad about something what do you want me
to do throw the presents out because i
will
i don't need this
or a rolex or some song that billy
eilish wrote for me personally no
throwing them away is even worse
how god you're being impossible
then don't be with me
what
[Music]
oh
oh thank god i found you in the first
room i checked
i have to tell you something there was a
scheme to break you and jamie up but i
heroically stopped it
i also started it
it was my scheme
what
i'm sorry
i guess i wanted you guys to break up
because
i like jamie i know
daisy told me that [ __ ] is lying sorry
reflex
just
look i want jamie to be happy and he's
happy with you
i'm the one who got him all the gifts
you have no reason to be jealous
jealous i don't get jealous honey i'm
dope god
you're so confident you would be too if
you had feet as big and beautiful as i
do i can't wait so
if you weren't jealous then why are you
so upset because
at school jamie and i we don't seem all
that different but being in this big
fancy house watching him open all those
expensive gifts it
it made me feel weird
i mean i don't have money to buy him an
oculus
i didn't even get him anything for his
birthday
don't laugh but
that's why i was in here i was trying to
make him a gift
yo holy god what is that thing it's
supposed to be jamie
huh
let me give you some advice
jamie doesn't need things
especially not a haunted painting from
hell
he just needs to know that you care
about him
he really likes you
he does
yeah
and love across class lines happens all
the time
my dad was rich but my mom was just hot
aren't your parents divorced yeah i was
never gonna work they're from two
different worlds
hey jamie how you will not
i'm hanging in there what the hell i'm
not dead no but you're leaving
what am i supposed to do text you call
you hang out after school and on the
weekends cause we're kids and we have no
obligations yeah
and i'm still here for another six weeks
come on there's got to be a way you can
stay at bayside i mean what if you move
to the palisades there's a house for
sale in my neighborhood yeah the floor
plan is kind of claustrophobic but i
know a great contractor i can't afford a
house i can't afford spotify without
commercials well what if you just say
you live at my house no that's illegal
please just too i can't chill my resting
body temp is 102. i'm like a labrador
i got to go to class
i will miss you
i got your text what's going on
so i thought about what you said
how i needed to be more chill
and i thought what better way to be
chill than to chill together for the
rest of our lives no
no no no no come on out boys
no boys
[Music]
is
[Music]
aisha this has been the best month and a
half or whatever of my life
will you make me the happiest dude in
homeroom and marry me no this is insane
get a hug no it's not that insane i mean
i love you and if we were married we'd
have the same address and you could stay
at bayside i thought that's what you
wanted i do but she said i do
i'm tired of people making decisions for
me
i didn't decide to come here and i
didn't decide to leave
and now you're just deciding that we
should get married i know this is crazy
but we have to do something
no i have to do something
hey aisha um can we talk about that sort
of insane thing i did earlier
uh
no need
i'm perfectly happy pretending that it
never happened
listen you know i love pretending i mean
right before you got here i was
pretending this mechanical pencil is a
big scary needle
ah
look i don't want to
pretend in our relationship
i want to be real
okay
uh
i've done a pretty bad job of listening
to you all day but i am finally paying
attention
for example i can tell that you don't
want to be having this conversation
right now
and i also noticed that you don't mind
the idea of not seeing me every day
and i noticed that you cringed when i
said the word love
but
i can't help how i feel
i do love you
okay sorry i did just cringe yeah but
i really like you
and i'm having fun
i know but
when someone doesn't feel the same way
about you that you feel about them it's
not a good fun
it's a sad fun like a
cruise man
this is over isn't it
yeah
i think it might be
[Music]
be honest
did i make a huge mistake with jamie
aisha you don't need me to tell you what
to do you got this yeah
so i'll be mature and give him space no
stop being an idiot and go tell him how
you feel god this is the microwave all
over again
i'm gonna go talk to you
you